\
For certain characters within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, fans may be hard-pressed to imagine
any other actor in that role-- especially
since most performers in Marvel Studios' shared
universe have played their character in one
or two — or more — films.
But, as is the case in the casting process
on any feature, there were multiple people
up for key roles.
For both Captain America and Iron Man, other
actors were eventually beat out by Chris Evans
and Robert Downey Jr.
In honor of those who lost out to the MCU's
Avengers roster, here are Screen Rant's 10
Marvel movie castings you didn't know almost
happened.
John Krasinski as Peter Quill
Before Marvel officially cast Chris Evans,
The Office's John Krasinski was a frontrunner
for Captain America.
Then, a few years later, the comedy actor
was on the shortlist for another MCU role,
this time as Peter Quill a.k.a. Star-Lord
in James Gunn's Guardians of the Galaxy.
But, although the part eventually went to
fellow sitcom star Chris Pratt, Krasinski
wasn't even the second choice for Star-Lord.
That honor belongs to Glenn Howerton of It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia fame.
It's clear, at least, that Gunn had a very
specific type of actor in mind for the part
of Star-Lord, though it may be difficult to
imagine anyone other than Chris Pratt in the
film.
Josh Hartnett as Loki
Before Kenneth Branagh's Thor went into production,
there were plenty of rumors surrounding both
the key role and the part of his brother Loki,
the God of Mischief.
Before the role eventually went to Tom Hiddleston
—who also screen-tested for the lead as
Thor — Loki was rumored to be played by
Josh Hartnett.
However, shortly after Chris Hemsworth locked
down the role of Thor, Hiddleston was cast
as Loki, leaving us to wonder what could have
been if the God of Mischief had been played
by Hartnett.
Emily Blunt as Black Widow
Before Scarlett Johansson signed on to Iron
Man 2 as Natasha Romanoff, the role belonged
to Emily Blunt.
However, contractual obligations to 20th Century
Fox caused the actress to drop out and star
in Gulliver's Travels.
Johansson landed the role in Iron Man 2 as
well as all following appearances of Black
Widow in the MCU.
Later, Blunt was rumored to be up for the
role of Peggy Carter in Captain America: The
First Avenger, but reportedly passed because
she didn't want a part that was simply a love
interest - the role has since been played
by Hayley Atwell in multiple movies and her
own TV series on ABC.
Liam Hemsworth as Thor
Although Chris Hemsworth auditioned for the
lead in Kenneth Branagh's Thor, he wasn't
chosen for the shortlist of five actors, and
originally wasn't even given a call-back.
His brother Liam, however, was among the final
five actors whittled down to play Thor.
But, when Branagh decided none of the five
actors were quite right for the part, Chris's
manager pushed his name forward - and he was
eventually chosen as the God of Thunder.
Olivia Wilde as Gamora
The alien assassin Gamora was played by Zoe
Saldana in Guardians of the Galaxy, but before
she was cast in the role, Marvel Studios reportedly
offered it to Olivia Wilde.
The actress was one of the final contenders
along with Gina Carano and Adrianne Palicki
— both of whom went on to star in other
Marvel Comics properties.
According to the report, Wilde passed on the
role as Gamora in favor of another project,
paving the way for Saldana to star in one
of Marvel's most popular films.
Jason Momoa as Drax the Destroyer
Although WWE star Dave Bautista portrayed
Drax the Destroyer in the final Guardians
of the Galaxy film, the overly-literal alien
was almost played by Jason Momoa.
Marvel even went as far as to commission concept
art of Momoa as Drax, but the actor ended
up turning down the part in fear of being
typecast after his roles in Game of Thrones
and Conan the Barbarian.
However, both the actors and audiences won
out in the end since Bautista nearly stole
the show as Drax, and Momoa landed a different
superhero role in the DC Extended Universe
as Aquaman.
Sam Rockwell as Iron Man
A number of big name actors were considered
for Jon Favreau's Iron Man, a film that would
launch the Marvel Cinematic Universe as we
know it.
Tom Cruise is the most notable name to have
been in talks for the role, but Sam Rockwell
was also on the shortlist to play Iron Man.
However, Rockwell was beat out by Robert Downey
Jr., who has since gone on to be one of the
most recognizable faces of the MCU.
Rockwell did of course appear in Iron Man
2, playing Tony's rival Justin Hammer.
Joaquin Phoenix as The Hulk
Similar to Spider-Man, The Hulk is a Marvel
Comics character who has been portrayed by
a number of different actors in the past two
decades.
Eric Bana starred in Ang Lee's Hulk, while
Edward Norton wore the iconic purple shorts
in The Incredible Hulk and was then replaced
by Mark Ruffalo for The Avengers.
But, even more actors have been attached to
the role of the Hulk in his many incarnations,
including Jeff Goldblum, Tom Cruise, and Joaquin
Phoenix.
According to rumors, Phoenix was Marvel's
top choice to play the Hulk in The Avengers,
but Ruffalo joined the cast instead.
Years later, Phoenix was reportedly in talks
for the lead in Marvel's Doctor Strange, but
again the studio went in another direction,
casting Benedict Cumberbatch as the Sorcerer
Supreme.
Rachel McAdams as Pepper Potts
Before joining the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in Doctor Strange, Rachel McAdams was previously
up for another key role: that of Pepper Potts
in Iron Man.
She was offered the part in Jon Favreau's
film but turned it down in favor of other
projects.
Instead, Gwyneth Paltrow co-starred alongside
Robert Downey Jr. in Iron Man, as well as
its two sequels.
Now, McAdams will join the mystical side of
the MCU as a currently undisclosed character
alongside Benedict Cumberbatch in Doctor Strange.
Channing Tatum as Captain America
Chris Evans has publicly stated time and time
again that he was hesitant to join the burgeoning
Marvel Cinematic Universe as Steve Rodgers
- and it was his friends Robert Downey Jr
and Mark Ruffalo who eventually persuaded
him to take the role.
But, before Evans threw his hat into the ring,
a number of other actors were considered for
the role, including Friday Night Lights' Scott
Porter, Twilight's Kellan Lutz, and even dancer-turned-actor
Channing Tatum.
Though fans may wonder what Captain America:
The First Avenger would have looked like with
Tatum in the lead role, the role of Steve
Rogers eventually went to Evans.
Johnny Depp as Doctor Strange
Before Benedict Cumberbatch joined the cast
of Marvel's mystical origin film as the Sorcerer
Supreme, a number of actors were rumored for
the role, including Joaquin Phoenix and frequent
Tim Burton collaborator Johnny Depp.
However, Phoenix is more a fan of crafting
independent films than starring in big superhero
blockbusters - especially if those comic book
flicks come with signing contracts for multiple
movies.
Depp, for his part, was already locked into
Disney's Pirates of the Caribbean, continuing
on as the fan favorite scoundrel Captain Jack
Sparrow.
So, Stephen Strange will instead be portrayed
by Cumberbatch as he joins the MCU in Doctor
Strange.
It may be hard to imagine what these Marvel
movies would have looked like if someone else
had been cast in the lead roles, but are there
any actors you would have preferred to play
Captain America or Iron Man?
Let us know in the comments and be sure to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one!